oh my god
what's going through your mind right now
i need silence
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this is season three season
finale of tacos
what's up
you chillin
yeah we shooting a show about tacos
can we get on the whole crew
[Laughter]
oh sorry about that have a go on we're
here at the iron maiden of taco shops
evil cooks it's a diabolically delicious
spot we haven't seen them since last
season and i want to see what they've
been up to you know it's going to be
damn good food we're about to go in have
a good time eat some delicious food with
a very special guest none other than
leslie jones ghostbuster snl star
stand-up comedian beast she was in new
york for a little bit and now she's back
in l.a so what better way to have a
homecoming than here at evil cooks i
should have brought a rosary cause we're
about to go dine with the devil leslie
what's up
how are you how are you doing
here thank you man this is great i love
tacos do you really no seriously i
[ __ ] love tacos where does that come
from first of all i'm from memphis
tennessee in memphis tacos is not what
y'all have out here it's like the ortega
set yeah what i'm saying with the hard
shells right your gran your grandmama
seasoned the meat really yeah shred the
cheese i'm so bomb
but when we moved out ahead of
california was when i really figured out
oh those
i remember
a person i work with was like yeah [ __ ]
you not eating real tacos
taco bell [ __ ] let me take you to get
some tacos la is the epicenter of tacos
does it surprise you that one of the
best taco spots is in the backyard of a
house not at all because i used to get
them from the little carts and all of
that so no it does not surprise me at
all am i supposed to be sweating you
wanted me to say yeah well i thought you
were that surprised
spanish people in l.a know how to cook
tacos at their house i would have never
i just wanted all this tag but man man
let me tell you we have one of the best
spots here this is evil cooks evil cooks
yeah evil cookies evil though how do you
feel about pentagrams what the hell is
the pentagram first of all you ain't
even got to tell me that
it's a devil star thing
no devil taco
well that's what they got here we're
about to summon an amazing menu we got
something real special for you you
hungry yes let's do it let's do it
[Music]
hi my name is elvia hey what's up i'm
alex people cooks heavy metal taqueria
here in los angeles we're known for our
black el pastor trompo
and our dessert tacos pandemic kids we
started popping up in the front of the
yard
everything's a diamond effect we didn't
expect it evokes comes because
the legend says because we were tired of
being good cooks so we're like we were
like [ __ ] it let's do something
different people say like my grandma
doesn't do do it that way like i'm sorry
for your grandma camacaze is a tasty
menu that we offer like every friday
here at the house so it's limited
sitting we serve them something a set
menu we can
create something on the spot today we're
serving some
requests from the guests carnitas or
carnitas light are bracing own uses the
carnitas comes with our pickled onions
and use lemon some some jalapenos and
chiles manzanos and orange zest and also
we're gonna serve our chorizo verde we
make the green cherries in house we
grind our own pork we add all these
herbs a pasote cilantro spinach
watercress to make it green and add a
lot of flavor comes like in a soft
scrambled omelet with some queso fresco
and pistachios on the top the heaven and
hell is basically a flower tortilla with
a crunchy taco inside filled with some
picadillo some shredded sharp cheddar or
salsa camada
one of the new ones our cotton candy rib
that's uh rib with barbecue cotton candy
and we're gonna add some gold beautiful
flowers and some salsa on top make it
fun make it fun our dessert is our
camote so it's our hybrid chocolate
tortilla
our camote
de leche which is vanilla ice cream
that's a hibiscus marmalade that we use
and also we add some sesame
seed candy meant to give that freshness
we're excited about this i've been
talking about it for a week really
thinking about
the menu so i hope they like it
so they're gonna prepare the meal now
yeah and while we wait
i have a very special drink for you this
is called ponche so it's almost like i
don't shave with a bee yeah punch is
like punch so it's a cider apple
cinnamon like it got all kinds of stuff
all right here we go i'm gonna taste
what do you think of that
yeah yeah
success she loves it
what do you think what does that really
matter [ __ ] kid drink right
there girl
all right all right this is the first
round this is the first one okay what do
we eat we're gonna bring all of them out
oh my gosh we're gonna bring out the
whole foods this is the carnitas
okay i can eat it no i call this heaven
and hail that's uh
okay this is our in-house green chorizo
and this is our cotton candy rib cotton
candy on the front that's gold they got
gold in the tacos so this is just main
course right here right here
tacos see so this is yours with c4 and
four here make sure you make sure you
get yours cause i will smack you
all right thank you but before you guys
go i want you guys to meet a dear friend
of mine jones how are you doing
nice to meet you
so you guys met at a concert correct we
met in a mosh pit in a mosh pit y'all
was jumping on each other pretty much
she punched me in the face my glasses
flew away
[Music]
and she gave it to me and i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm in love but what made you start
like doing we both cook they worked on
some of the best kitchens here in la and
they decided to run with it oh that's
how you get this culinary experience
well i'm ready let's do it what are we
starting with leslie i'm starting i
don't carnitas ketchup
we're doing carnitas
oh my god
what's going through your mind right now
i need silence cuz
what do you do that's so [ __ ] good
i'm telling you this is like top-notch
these though these guys do not miss
everything seriously i have to put that
up there with like the best conicals
i've ever had so that was the opener
oh my god
you want to try this sear cheese one
that's a salsa
okay well roja into my mouth
and then you see little pistachios up
top oh okay so get a good bite of that
one
oh my god
oh my god there's like an omelette in
the taco yeah with the syrup cheese
oh my god that is so good that i'm good
i haven't tasted this one this is like
bananas
i'm gonna be honest i didn't think i was
gonna like this one i was looking at it
going
let's go into
i don't know let's do uh okay we're
gonna do this it's a crunchy time i
can't say the gold one for last yeah go
on for last we got to end it on the oh
my god okay how do we eat this so this
is the tortillas on the bottom it got
melted cheese inside
beef
[ __ ] me man [ __ ] that
oh i'm sorry
oh
pop
didn't i tell you this was gonna be off
the hook okay you know when somebody
started sweating
that's when you know they're eating
father god
oh my god yeah they made it just for you
nah they ate this before no they i mean
they got everything's near you is for
you see see how i inspire folks
hey
[Applause]
oh my god
i love crunchy tacos the meat is
seasoned
perfectly so well
i'm overwhelmed like i need to be at
home this is not a a meal i want to eat
in front of everybody
you know what i'm saying i heard of all
these guys you know what i'm saying i
want to like be on the couch with
something like really good on tv just
devour you know what i'm saying like no
clothes maybe maybe a t-shirt man you
know something like that comfy and like
a big ass like soda or something or what
or bouche or buche bunche
and just like [ __ ] it up y'all don't
have [ __ ] postmates you better get
[ __ ] postmates stop
bullshitting i'ma drive right here what
time you close you better get their
number before you leave
would you say that you are the comic now
that you wanted to be when you first
started coming absolutely oh my god i'm
the person i wanted to be really first i
manifested
never thought i would be this leslie
jones never in the [ __ ] million years
you have to work to know how to give joy
out of yourself and that is a
thing that you develop with yourself
doing comedy helped me do it because a
lot of stuff that i would talk about is
stuff that was going on with me and i
learned how to express myself
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you a dmx quote
that i've always believed in he may not
come when you call but he's always on
time and that quote reminds me of you
because this goes back to way back to
where i first met you i was working at
the store i was parking your car but i
literally saw you
as you got snl and things just took off
would you mind telling us kind of like
the the step by step of what happened
like i was at the comedy store late spot
11 45 and chris rock came in and owen
smith was sitting in the back he said he
said that chris came in and listened to
me do the joke and he was like
next level they took out his phone and
typed and typed in my name and then on
was like what you doing he was like i'm
putting on the funny person list so
three days later he called me and he was
like yeah i just had dinner with lauren
and they're gonna call you in for an
audition the way they set the audition
up it's very scary it's like you know no
people in the room
uh people sitting in the back you know
you can't see them much like saturday
night at two o'clock in the morning hot
spots yeah so
so i was like i'm just gonna make it fun
cause i'm probably not gonna get this
job
so the stage manager was like yo you
gotta walk straight just walk straight
to the stage you know if you've been
down in snl it looks like a catacomb so
instead of walking straight to the stage
i wa i turned to the right and was right
behind the bleachers and i knew that
they were sitting right there so i'm
behind the bleachers and and he was like
what what are you doing i was like chris
is that your name
where am i supposed to go
he comes he's like how the [ __ ] did you
end up here
you told me he was like no i told you to
go straight straight
but it's not this he said no the stage
is that way you all [ __ ] see the
stage so they are dying they're dying so
i finally made my way to the stage i got
on the stage and i was like hey you guys
are sitting too far back bring your ass
up here i don't do that i need energy
you brought long monsters i got the
energy from the crowd
and they all just got up and walked to
the front and i treated that [ __ ] like
it was a a spot
at the store even ended it we're like yo
my name is leslie jones peace
that's free
when i hear this story all i see is like
you being fearless and funny and
unapologetically yourself it's like
people say that fearless thing i
understand the word but i i don't really
understand it i mean everybody
everybody's scared everybody in this
motherfucker's scared everybody you
still get nervous
[ __ ] yeah and you if you do not
man if you don't you don't give a [ __ ]
about this [ __ ] right everybody has
courage everybody gets up every morning
and [ __ ] walk out the house you are a
brave ass [ __ ] because life is
life so so like really take that [ __ ]
like it's not about it's not about being
scared or having fear it's about what
you do when you have that fear that's
courage
that's [ __ ] courage everybody thinks
that you need to be a hero and like this
[ __ ] to eat wheaties no be human
be honest with your [ __ ] self yeah
and i find that a lot in young people is
that that they don't understand that
falling down is important it's part of
the journey do you know that's the only
way you know how to get up is cause you
fell down you got to go through somebody
coming going you ain't funny yo i don't
know if you should be doing it you got
to go through it you got to get insulted
so hard because if you go it's on fire
yeah i'm telling you go home i used to
go home and cry my pillow and still be
like i'm going up tomorrow night though
yeah you know if if you still want to do
it after that you really want to do it
[ __ ] all right
all right
what i got to do so we we close it up
and we're going to pull this bonus oh
this requires some oh is this going to
work yeah it's not going to work look
see yours did it
what made you think they put cotton
candy in it that is amazing what is that
barbecue like barbecue sugar sugar so
why not turn it into cotton candy i damn
good
that's damn good
i give them a thumbs up
and two snaps in the circle
this is a dessert taco
it's like a mote con leche
well jam and what we have in the bottom
is a
hybrid tortilla it's corn and flour
oh it's chocolate so chocolate and
chocolate's in there too yeah wow
mexican chocolate and then you have the
jams
and some hibiscus marmalade some uh
vanilla ice cream and uh sesame seeds
candy
okay so we we eat it like a taco like a
taco taco okay
it's gonna be
all right all right i'm gonna watch you
[Music]
it looks good okay i want to taste it
yeah
but do i taste wow i don't understand
how the ice cream
you just bought ooh jesus whipped
god
hey like this
calling children
man i did not think i was gonna like
this i'm i'm telling you that don't miss
i did not they don't miss this
that is [ __ ] good the yams and
everything right the biscuits
the little sweet taste that comes
through
you're so sweet i appreciate you thank
you
100 let me tell you about jesus he used
to park my car yeah and i think i went
through two cars right the centra and
then the ultimate oh god
you knew me did you go to that party
where we did mushrooms no i wish i did i
wasn't invited oh
oh man i didn't invite you so i liked
you i'll never forget how sweet you've
always been i mean i remember opening
for you in la jolla you're just such a
force to be reckoned with the whole
thing was always focused on all your
successes thank you congrats on yours
i'm i'm trying this is so crazy
you should see the calling that she has
now she's so funny now every time i see
him perform obviously like see that's
what uh continuously going up and
[ __ ] being humble to the craft gets
you i'm gonna give you a big hug thank
you so much baby i'm a passport
thank you so much for being here that
was so great this is the leslie jones
episode
evil cooks
third season
juanitas tacos
this is the finale finale in spanish
that's it
[Music]
hello my name is jesus i'm the host of
tacos contolo and don't forget to like
and subscribe you can watch more right
here hurry watch another episode before
your boss comes in and you get fired for
real this time